якщо наші антикорупційні органи не
знають адресу куди завітати то хочу їм
сказати вулиця Банкова там сьогодні день
народження святкує Андрій Єрмак може до
нього завітати набу привітати його там є
з чим привітати там є кого привітати там
є про що поговорити там нам сьогодні
говорять і про біткоїни і про інше думаю
там можна поговорити про все тому
шановний саб шановне набу підказую вам
адресу куди можна завітати і куди треба
завітати якщо ми реально хочемо боротися
з корупцією викорінювати саме
викорінювати тобто братися за корень
корінь який пророс на вулиці банковій і
це є правда тому що без цього не було б
всього цього бардаку який сьогодні
відбувається в державі не було б бе
скінченних цих справ які не зупиняються
і які люди обурюються дивлячись на те що
відбувається тому що коли ми говоримо
про корупцію не в час війни то це одна
іще історія А коли ми говоримо про
корупцію під час війни Коли ми бачимо
підозр на мільярди в Міноборони Ну так
це ж просто неймовірно це питання
виживання держави тож беріться за
реальне коріння годі по вершках бігати
беріться за коріння виривайте його з
корнем і тоді буде результат дякую